[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] It's a
strange dream.
My name is Naofumi Iwatani
and a second-year college student in Numazawa.
I was able to enjoy the life of Ota Ward without having to work part-time, and I was able to enjoy the life of Ota Ward.
It was just a mediocre nerd with
nothing strange.
Until I picked up this book, I
woke up in the western part of the city.
Summon four heroes from another world to save the world from the disaster-causing waves of the weekend.
Each of the four heroes uses a
bow shield as a weapon.
No, it's more armor than a weapon. The
body is wide and it doesn't come out at all. This princess is a
[ __ ].
I
wonder if it's the story of the main characters of all four people.
Where's this Cocoa
What's this Vertically
[Music]
Good guy, please save this world
Taste,
what does that mean? There are various complicated circumstances, but due to the
nc ritual, your legend  I summoned a city tax hero.
Attitude is a child. The word "the legendary hero of four of us."
This world is in danger of survival right now
.
Well, there are only five stories. Well
, will you
return to the original world? The story is then. Do you feel guilty about forcibly calling? If it becomes peaceful, it will be returned to the original world.  It ’s just a job.
How much will you pick up this stone?
Depending on the story, we may be your target.
First of all, I would like you to listen to the cherry blossoms of Merlomark in Japan
. Please negotiate the bounty after that
. There seems to be room for thinking.
You came to the
store  It's a nice breeze,
it's like a pamphlet for overseas travel
. Isn't it impossible to get out of Japan? From the
outside wind, it's the same mechanism as the pillars
.  Is it a
brave man who has been handed down from ancient
times?  I'm a 17-year-old high school student. It's
me at the end.
I'm Juri in Motoyasu in the year
.
It ’s okay to be a king.
Well,
my name is Naofumi Iwatani, a 20-year-old college student.
First of all, I have to explain the situation
.
I'm angry at the attitude of this. I'm in
this world. There is
a prediction of the weekend, and it seems that the parallels that lead to the ruin of the world
come in multiple
layers.
Gacco has a long-standing tool called the Tatsuya hourglass,
so you know when it's coming.
The first wave struck this country before we were summoned.
And the adventurers managed to get rid of the first wave,
the second and third waves became even more powerful The
hourglass continued to shed sand until the waves stopped rushing, and by
the second wave it was already less than a month
We had a sweet look at the waves, but when we
actually saw them, we realized
that only the heroes of the city administration could counter them,
and we summoned you according to the tradition.
It's not
exactly the same as the book I just read. Yeah, I
understand the story, so it's not redeemed and it's not unpaid.
Of course, I rejected the waves, but I'll give you enough rewards in the month.
It's okay if you promise me, but I'll cooperate unless it's regular, but I
think you
can make it sound cute.
Check their status
What's the status
? You're the first to notice when you come to this world. I
wonder if that information 2 is so cute. Is there an
icon at the edge of your view?
Do you try it
? Kouko 4 a Level 1 Is
this anxiety? That's right. I don't know if I can fight.
This is a
low + magical ability that can only be used by heroes.
So what should we do?  However, I will go on an adventure trip and
grow and strengthen the processed legendary weapons.
Isn't it strong from the beginning?
Fixed price My app article I don't even have to use other club expenses until it becomes usable
I think we should clean up there later. Anyway, we should polish ourselves
. It's just raising the level.
Please wait if we form a party with four of us. Brave-sama,
brave-sama are friends separately.  Why are you going on an adventure
? B It is said that each legendary weapon has a repulsive nature, and if you
report it together, it will hinder your growth. It
seems to be true.
It seems that the legendary weapon is being converted to Japanese. The
day is tilting. I'm taking a rest today.
I'm going to leave tomorrow
.
It seems that a hero has been summoned. All the seals in this country are
okay. It's a hero of the shield. After
all, it's nice to be treated as a hero of the
legend.  But it was gorgeous.
Well, it's like a game. It's not a game. It's not like
Emerald Online. It's a lie game.
Oh, it's super famous.
It ’s the world of games. It ’s
different from Dimension web. It ’s vrm.
It ’s almost the same as Brave star online. It ’s
because of the information. It ’s okay to say
vrmmo as it is.
I feel like it was in a game of things, isn't it? It
's a confirmation of common sense just in case I remember reading it.
And the name of the Prime Minister who took the dismantling Sado 6
B. It seems that we came from different Japan. That's right.
I don't think it's the same
. Did you think that the reason why Japan in a good world exists is only in different times?  I don't think it's the same so far. I wonder if
everyone is playing a game that looks exactly like this world.
Why don't I just know why?
Something is wrong.
So Motoya,
as far as I know, it's a seal. The shield is the main food. Ah, the
high level is the profession of the loser since then
.
And my mother, it's
almost the same as the terrain I know. The hunting grounds for each weapon are different, so I don't go to the same place
.
]
Vertically, it's a building time that prevents enemy attacks and protects allies. In the
original world, there was no connection, but it
may be love. It's
okay. It
's a different world of cliffs.
I'll do my best It's a
weed It's the beginning of an adventure tomorrow Let's
go back to the room and fall asleep today
[Music] Now
my big adventure begins
[Music]
tan Face up with the legendary heroes
I wonder if these people who recruited such things will become our companions. My
mother also has good children.
Come on, please leave for the nutrition of the future.
As expected, if such a situation occurs,
there is no hope that there will be no victims. There is a
tree where such rumors are spreading
. In fact, there are rumors that the hero of the shield is ignorant of this world.  It's been whispered in.
Ahhh, it's said
that joining the company understands this world. It
's not that it doesn't meet that condition.
It wasn't the chat eavesdropping last night.
I'm certainly not familiar with it, but
they curry, if you have five of you, please share me. I don't like to hang
out
.  Kaa
[Music]
Booburn doesn't seem to be sloppy, but it's irritating.  It's better to open them one by one,
but it seems that you'll be involved in the ceremony by force, so I don't want to
eat it alone
.
Is it okay to go to my own brave
man? I already
have a hen, and
this child will be my companion.
Before there is a possibility that it
is okay to go to  Let's increase the amount more than other heroes.
Then, I will receive it firmly as a preparation.
I prepared 800 silver coins for Fumi and 600 for others
.
I'll protect my mother's queen firmly,
but I can't help you, but
please do your best to gather friends. When the time comes, again
[Music]
Hero of the Shield to the Great My name is Minsphere.
Nice to meet you, I
'm relieved to be a
kind of seedling.
But I've become a companion for me like this. I have
to protect it
.  Music]
I glanced at it yesterday, but when I look closer, it feels like a different world.
What will the brave man do from now on?
First of all, I want to go to a store that sells weapons and armor.
6th c Then
I'll show you to a good shop that I know. I'll
ask you. It's cute. It's
a girl's companion
. This is the recommended shop.
The place of life that entered the house is different, isn't it? I
was gradually introduced to him.
By the way
, he has nothing to do with his specially dressed boyfriend day
Oh,
my dad
is a rumored hero with Anne,
or hey.
I wonder if it will be transmitted.
Yes, if you care about it, you will lose.
I'm Naofumi Iwatani.
Thank you. Fumi
Inu It doesn't matter what it's like if you're good at it.
With about 250 pieces of
silver ash, the effect of iron magic iron magic steel silver is different from the left, but it's not
endorsed. Yes, if I had this, I drank it.
It looked like it was
smashed. It's really a forbidden matter. It's just a fight.
It seems that I can't use other weapons for the spirits of this building
.
[Music] It's
a small shield when it's restored.
I can buy this house with a deaf person, but it seems strange that I can't talk from my body.
I feel some powerful power here, but I don't understand the magic of appraisal.
It looks like it's a little like that, isn't it? Ah,
how much extra is the price
, and
it's 120 silver coins. That's right. If it's a signal item, I'd buy it for 100 galaxies
.  If you grow up, you won't be able to enter it,
so I asked you how much it would cost if you sold it
.
[Music]
[Applause] I
can absorb as much as I want
ran
This is the power of the legendary weapon
. I think it's because of this that it doesn't hurt.
It seems that you have to inhale it.
By the way, it's possible to sell this orange balloon after the mountain
.
The amount is about this,
and it seems that it will change as you level up.
Let's remove the club care again today. It's
better to buy my equipment tomorrow.
That's right,
Joe-chan's.  Equip
it. If you equip a good one to Ashika, you'll be stronger.
Hmmm, I'm a
brave man who didn't pull out so much that it was funny
.
none
is a cheap total I'll get a discount 4.8 million yen for an engineer I wo
n't lose any more If I
paint it, I'll get 200 climbing silver coins
.  It's okay, doctor, the stronger I get, the more I can make a dawn with the merchandise when I defeated the monster.
Thank you for the brave
new
person Oh yeah, where is this cheap mountain to buy? The person
who has a demon apology collection shop should buy it there.
Thank you
. The food served at delicious siro was delicious, but after all this  It feels like the real thrill of the Saiseikai.
Oh
, please enjoy it slowly. I don't
mind the grasslands that fought today.
Tomorrow, I'm heading to Rafa Village on this map
. There is a dungeon for beginners beyond that Rafa Village.
Honjo: I can't expect much of it, but
I think it's a good place for the brave to raise the level.
I see, the equipment has been renewed
.
Can't you drink
wine? Oreha-Isn't it so much? It's
quite delicious. I
want to drink with a brave man. My
husband suddenly became like Mitsuya, but
I'm sorry I'm not good at it.  Well, the chairman
is a brave man. What kind of thing is that this country has a female advantage, so
there is no man who refuses to drink alcohol that women promote.
That's right, I don't have to
worry about that kind of thing
from tomorrow.  I'm glad I was able to discuss the policy of the
hut I'm thinking of living early, but I
'm drinking a little more I'm lonely but
that dissatisfaction
Thank you  I'll
make up for the hut someday, so it's
okay. Good night,
brave man, snacks.
Unusual of 200 silver coins,
whether it's one night or 30 sheets, combined with 2
meals, 5 sheets, 2 meals
, 199 sheets, a little bit
like this, I feel like a Japanese who came to a foreign tourist destination
today.  I wonder if there were various things
like that in response to defeating monsters
Today it was like a balloon, but
horror
I really came to a different world
tan
[Music] It's
a hindrance
I
don't have a soldier tomorrow [Music] I'm about to leave for a meal with help I'm not a
member of the Diet I don't even have
a smell  Money and grass shoes Ah,
it's hard to get up if it's lame, isn't
it? It's a terrorist hero who heard the story that was just right like the father
of Andersche White.  Oh
[Music]
What the
hell was it all right?
Re
Umai
-sama I've stolen all my property
and all the equipment costs other than the tea shield.
What kind of thing do you want to catch the criminal?
It's a
pitiful adventurer, Mine,
but can't you testify again?
The hero of the shield suddenly enters the room by the Usa family and knows
me.
I managed to escape and stayed at the same inn by chance
. I stood here and Yasu-sama. I
had to wait until the morning and tell the person who called the model, I cut you off.
By the way,
what are you talking about? I'm sleeping in the room after the wife of Messi of the day.
It's a gift I got.
The hero of the shield is the hero of the shield who shouldn't have committed the most contraindications in Japan.
I'm not doing that,
Akira Akira Akira Akira I
was searching for the room of the hero of the shield
Yes,
this kind of thing is on the pet
Beast
Way Other evidence.
It wasn't like that when I woke up
.
Did you worry about
it? I misunderstood that a brave man would be forgiven for whatever he did. I didn't give him any special
treatment. You're not the
main character in this different world.
Yeah,
why are you that kind of thing, we're friends,
daddy
car, don't
say I'll be my friend, a bright red lie to trap me in this place
Heal the movie I showed you All
[Music] If
you
disturb me  Good
I was going to eat it first Ah ah
What the criminal should say I
'm not fooling around
I was aiming for my money and equipment Anyway you two showed me together
It seems easy to think about
me now  Even though I only called him the person who said it, I
called Motoyasu by name-
what if this wasn't proof?
I don't
think it's a mistake. It was a mistake to
summon it to the music. If I didn't join the company, I wouldn't be able to join the company.
And I wanted to carry things to my advantage
even a little.
Below, the cowardly and worst people. The guys in
Kuma Kuni don't believe in me.
I need it
[Music]
I don't care anymore, just
return me to the world I have, and let's digest anything even if I'm a new hero.
I have to feel like this until I come to another world.
It's the worst if I run away if it gets worse. I don't even try to do it with my seat Ma-chan.
All postures can be summoned only when the hero dies, but if you
can't put it in as it is,
or if all the looming waves are rejected, the sound will be with him in the kiln for returning to the original world.
I don't know if I have to fight in
Contamination There is no grace until the next wave Even if it
rots, you are only in the waves  It's a brave man who can fight against you,
but it's already known to your sins and the people
. It's a
punishment.
Before
I guess a lot, I'm weak
, I want time
tan
[Music] In this
way, I lost all my dignity as a hero of trust and honor.
I don't know what to do
I understand that it's a piece I've come
to the
start
Don't die I
thought
[Music]
tar I
'm finally at the level after fighting all night
, isn't it?
Thank you very much.
You
have a
cute
balloon balloon. Is
it 20 in Junbu? How about one? Didn't you
say 22 in the previous guy?
By the way, I don't think we're in business, isn't it? Is it possible to
sell it at a high price? Anzai City is
good.  But I wonder if it's a
house or a big palace
Hmm.
I wonder if negotiations have been concluded
.
There's no sin in any way. Spread my rumors about isole and sawn timber in the flower bed. Even if you don't say that you do
n't have a tooth profile all over your body for the playful music award, Hiroshi Kojima
will continue to favor you.
[  Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music] In
other words, the word that you can take over the ability even if you transform it vertically by using it is
Reef Shield
[Music]
Urajo Ko
This is quite a product.  Where is good
Shiro and it's a forest right away? Don't you know? If you
can get this kind of goods there, the room will be a
little worse.
[Music]
No matter what you eat from that day, it won't taste.
I'll be a friend of Tou's hero. Thank you so much. First
, check the contract details. L-Yes,
the employment form is complete.
I understand the meaning
.  It's a method of distribution.
I'll take the yuan, so I'll get at least 40%. The
rest will be distributed at my discretion
. Of course, if you don't do anything, there's no share.
If you play an active role with Jahn, you'll be able to open it. If you can play an active role
, let's go to the equipment immediately.
You can buy the equipment on your own
.
Speaking of which, I didn't have to waste time, but on the
contrary, the leader Juni
Ah ah ah,
I
have enough defense power but not enough attack power-
I can't defeat the monsters because I can't
defeat them.  I can't earn I can't
earn, so my attack power doesn't
increase forever. It's a nasty loop.
Pain
[Music] It
seems like you're in trouble.
It's not such an inconvenient thing to offer, so I'm
curious,
eh, you have my favorite eyes, you're like the
rumored person,
I know who I am  Of course, the
shield hero Span is here with me if you're done with it.
So what do you
offer me? I don't know, but
I'm a slave.  Is the cause of the slave victory and above all, because
when I want a slave,
they can't lie and can never do Brazilian things to their masters.
Slave can be severely cursed.
What kind of cooperation
do you
have? How about some peeping off meetings?
You seem to have the qualities to be a good customer. It
's okay if you're not human
.
Tell me more about this world.  A
person is just an opinion to humans, but the number of people's rooms that have different parts from humans is also
increasing.
Used for each shadow that makes 810 people fight each other Master
I see in the category
I think that life is treated as a slave in this human-use-oriented country because the sub-races are considered to be close to demons
.
[Music]
Eh
Hunting  The time of the air bomb I found The lost house is the world of fishing
. Look for an answer that can be instructed. However,
I used to work for w-like sales
.
anaal
[music]